electronic cigarettes they come in all
sorts of shapes and sizes but none of
them have tobacco or produce smoke they
just have a battery that heats up a
liquid often with nicotine to create a
vapor that's it but it's a new industry
and with anything new there's bound to
be some backlash we do not know right
now within the public health and medical
community what the long-term effects are
of the ingredients of e-cigarettes and
what inhaling those ingredients over
time could cause on the human body
Heather Whitley is the associate
director of the USC Institute for Global
Health she says we need more data before
we can determine the health effects of
electronic cigarettes e-cigarettes
currently exists in the complete no
man's land we don't want to have to find
generations later from now that there's
been disastrous secondhand exposures
from vapor that we were ignorant of at
the time and let other people be exposed
to that the idea that we should wait 30
40 50 years to collect long-term data on
electronic cigarettes before anyone in
the public health community can
seriously recommend them to smokers it's
a perverse interpretation of the
precautionary principle it's true that
long-term data won't be available for a
while but Greg comley's organization
that consumer advocates for smoke free
alternatives association sponsored a
comprehensive review by a Drexel
University professor that professor
concluded that there was absolutely no
worry about risk to bystanders from
e-cigarette vapor the study says that
there is no evidence that vaping
produces inhalable exposures to
contaminants of the aerosol that would
warrant health concerns but politicians
aren't listening
they are preventative ly regulating them
with local bands all over the country
like bands on using them indoors
essentially treating them like
traditional cigarettes users of
e-cigarettes who are using them to quit
smoking should be encouraged to use
those devices in areas and where they're
not putting others at risk of exposures
our policymakers in government should be
making all of their decisions based
science and data not on conjecture not
on well if it looks like a cigarette it
must be cigarette Craig Weiss is
president and CEO of n joy and joy is a
donor to Reason Foundation and a leading
manufacturer of electronic cigarettes
he says politicians should instead be
embracing this technology that has
proven much more effective and
government anti-smoking programs despite
all of these resources that have been
spent by the government they really
haven't made a really serious dent in
the last 10 years in the number of
people who smoke in this country and
what I think is amazing about what a
company like njoy is doing is we're
using technology and and that's what we
do in America we use technology to solve
really complicated problems so this
essentially boils down to regulation
versus innovation and it's not just
local legislation causing concern
top-down FDA regulations are on the
horizon what we expect to see are
regulations like ingredient disclosures
Good Manufacturing Practices age
verification things that will prevent
youth access to the product now Craig
says and Joe is fine with some
regulation but what if regulations turn
out to be more extensive how will
smaller businesses cope if the FDA tries
to apply all the same rules that they
apply to cigarettes as they do to
electronic cigarettes it would be a
disaster the small and medium-sized
businesses would have registration
requirements and hundreds of pages of
regulations to comply with almost every
single one of them would likely shut
down Conley says the FDA is looking into
regulating the liquid or ejuice which
would create all sorts of barriers the
availability of liquids is what is
allowing a lot of these small stores to
open and prosper because they're able to
mix their own liquid and sell it to
consumers without having to go through a
big manufacturing process all we're
doing is steaming up food ingredients to
create a steam or a vapor it's
comparable to the steam off of a coffee
cup or the steam from a hot shower yes
you can see it and it's physically there
but it just kind of dissipates meet EDF
where's oh he is co-owner of the vape
studio in West Los Angeles one of the
many vape stops popping up and
regulators are worried about their
ingredients in manufacturing processes
where is that Edie
says are unfounded let's just go over
the anatomy of an electronic cigarette
basically consists of a battery that
provides voltage to a heating element
now the heating element is either soaked
in what they call a juice or a liquid we
use food grade ingredients propylene
glycol is USP kosher food grade our
vegetable glycerin is USP kosher food
grade and we source our flavors from
reputable food flavoring companies our
liquid nicotine is actually laboratory
grade liquid nicotine and that's about
it there's a four ingredients this
customizable ejuice also allows for
varying levels of nicotine depending on
what the consumer wants it needs some
don't want nicotine at all people who
would get like an on nicotine vape juice
because they don't want the nicotine
they don't want to feel like they're
addicted to doing this that actually is
our best seller well enjoy stated
mission is to help smokers quit and says
vape shops like his are becoming more
than that they're creating a new culture
of vaping that's what this has become
it's it's something that someone can do
that looks cool and feels good and they
do with their friends and not have all
the harmful effects of smoking a
traditional cigarette so could be
cigarettes completely replace cigarettes
is the new cool thing without the side
effects but still to be determined
but Weiss is hopeful that the momentum
of the industry will quash pointless
politics the electronic cigarette
industry is growing at a quite a
dramatic pace it's more than doubled
each of the last four or five years and
we're on pace right now according to
some tobacco analysts to hit well over a
billion dollars in retail sales in the
United States only in 2013 this piece of
technology could have such a potential
impact on the world
you